Buddhist monks were a symbol of hope and
defiance during the dark years of
Myanmar's military dictatorship
but as the country opens up to the world
they've taken a radical turn
Muslims account for less than 10% of
Myanmar's population today rising
sectarianism is driving more and more of
them out of the country
for 30 years sway men ran this bicycle
repair shop with a diverse mix of
Buddhist Muslim Christian and Hindu
customers but in July false rumors that
a Muslim man had raped a Buddhist woman
triggered riots
Brutus mobs attacked Muslim homes and
businesses in Mandalay the second
largest city two people were killed and
dozens were injured during the riots
when Elena's sitting on my junk we put
on tsunami loves egg and yoga and yes
DNA Yamaha and it's a cool anomaly and
duty out they needed it look you're off
to - javis woman's wife since this
happened
do you feel safe here the Mandalay orgy
once
the median young she got out of aluminum
movie cavity well-pleaded me I got she
needs it
who's responsible
to feel like it is getting worse from
Muslims here in Mandalay and around me
in month
the Buddhist mobs the targeted Muslims
over the summer marked the first such
attack in a major city outside the
mosque where swimming said his last
prayers these policemen stand guard
I've actually my heart beating
oh no ah no ah gracias
some people have said that when there's
been bounced of violence over the past
couple of years that they me and more
police have turned a blind eye to
attacks on Muslims
but Muslim leaders tell a different
story
one of normal Hamid is head of the
Judith God Eddie died me about my
adoption in or something I never even
imagined that yeah why do you think this
kind of discrimination and these attacks
are becoming more common today to the
world community
hey honey before yoga is happening
who do you think was behind it
the man no one wants to name is a
chinois to the face of radical Buddhism
in Myanmar in his sermons
he's called Muslims mad dogs who must be
removed from the country if the Buddhist
majority is to be safe and it was raw to
stoke the Mandalay riots by posting the
rape fabrication on his Facebook account
his hate mongering campaign has harmed
Buddhists as well
Nene mins husband Thun Thun was killed
during the summer ayats by Muslims
seeking vengeance I know to you that the
room / - nen Antonov oh no - I knew the
a a tornado Noah - Noah - Noah - Caleb
you okay we'll see you perform our video
Kaname be positive returns allow for
transmission automatic aerosol cool air
from up your Lumia Wooley I see here in
your living room any images of Buddhist
monks and leaders what's your opinion of
we're oh come on Eva generally love your
queen eternally cool they got another
little apartment in it or no never so
why they all love you
who need him I'm hung out over to me and
I'll let you know love you doesn't mean
II don't want to see you I brought
enough not about Java really our
interview is interrupted by a government
agent okay yes so why did you interrupt
the interview my others are why I'm due
for one who is there officer my office I
was a manager in zinnia
can I speak with him he is going to the
young to Yangon
so who is the boss here near the bus
because we spoke with her we have her
permission to come interview
more than 2500 monks live in study under
wat - at is mandalay monastery as his
radicalism has increased so his his
following
there's a lot of tension right now
between Buddhists and Muslims around
Myanmar do you think there's a future
where both groups can live alongside
each other
nice
outside were on twos resents a poster
highlights alleged crimes committed by
Muslims against Buddhists so I have a
copy of Time magazine here the cover is
your picture and it says the face of
Buddhist terror what do you think of
this I mean evaluation it give my body
no general but you have gone out of your
way to cultivate this image you've
styled yourself the Buddhist bin Laden
you've said that President Obama has
Black Muslim blood is tainted and these
kinds of statements are inflammatory Oh
Cavalia you never glued a decent Muslim
you do not damage our hair and he do
never have a love story
do you know who John a lot of dog hired
a sarong they lie to you your message is
clearly very popular in Myanmar today
why do you think what you're preaching
is really taking root among people here
he bothered the who didn't change our
Connie erinbowley the denial oh my
change oh can you turn and Eleuthera
draw a pocket and I'm going to long- in
addition I had to long residue he cream
in the tony ibrehem unimodular
was leaning on to remove chill and our
jail time and I know she'll endure said
the road turning around and our
name-change Ocana
Posada Korean hold on when the violence
started here in Mandalay in early July
it was because of a false rumor that a
British woman had been raped by a Muslim
man but you went ahead and posted this
unverified rumor on your Facebook page
which is very popular and some accuse
you of stoking
that anger which led to the deaths of
two people including one Buddhist what
can you say to that
no general my name would Accord IMI's
I'm doing kilometer a local of you
cannot hear you neither Cooney be near
as a balloon my door da Vinci doll
before we left we wrought to showed us
his media lab he just opened this
account let's not shoot the next day we
met with Galan nice IATA a senior monk
and his monastery on the other side of
town
scientists spent 20 years in prison for
protesting against the military now he's
taking on Watsu during the riots syoss
spent two nights in the street working
to calm angry mobs that were looting
Muslim businesses I don't do Julia how
are we gonna do yeah well does he need a
hand if you know the Iranian how much
immunity - I'll have an easy in it yet
due to a change of the netvisn one and I
like your bow Munna - Munna but despite
all his efforts sighs I was anxious
about what the future has in store in
the air I don't eat awhile here is old
thing about in an ayah
bhadiya kill your daily minimum even the
other BMW in it - no good night Danny no
keys I'm silver the other need him at
Amara need him mama gonna kneel and in a
Chinese anniversary
no no hello Jen's I don't need a girl
more reputable haria Oh Lady I don't yet
have ever got over diversity of animal
or what - and his followers still
stirring up trouble and do mom about
what I generally hear nobody beside la
CIMA kinda move to another human a war
machine have any movement mommy forget
all the other very much my friend above
Allah
how delusional are they didn't have but
I am chilly for a rainy day